alors la question à se poser thierry
ardisson aurait pu aurait dû ou pas
défendre à des taux si oui et donc vous
coupe le monde et nous aurons tout ce
côté là effectivement là ce soir merci
d'avoir été là la mutation de
producteurs alors c'est vrai que c'est
parti dans tous les sens depuis ses
records il s'est dit plein de choses il
y aurait donc des émissions pays en
avant pour payer des impôts
en réponse à ça a été dit en tous les
cas en réponse à ça il ya eu un
instagram posté par après tout si où
elles révèlent des images qui ont été
coupées donc ça pose beaucoup de
questions fallait-il ou non est diffusé
ce que c'était son droit
donc forcément il ya il ya un sac de
noeuds assez compliqué mourrez vous
expliquer cette histoire précisément de
toute façon quoi qu'il en soit et là
j'ai eu mon la chaîne cet après-midi
réussir il on pense trop à la majorité
que ce qui a été dit par zemmour dans
l'édition est absolument abominable
l'émission dans l'émission opa ayant
donné ou des phrases prononcées en ce
qui me concerne que oui les choses qui
ne se disent pas et dans ce cas précis
c'est juste la phrase bien pour moi à ne
devait pas se dire parce qu'elle est
appelée le moins du monde voilà c'est
pour ça qu'elles ont été coupées
d'accord mais bon alors été dit dans ces
cas là on tourne dit n'importe quoi on
coupait mais c'est quand même dit ça me
laisse les gens moi je ne rendrai des
obligations benjamin une émission nous
c'est un tout petit peu dit lors d'un
point de vue on va les temps peut être
choqué par des ampoules et un de ses
premiers ballons peut les couper parce
que précisément ils sont choquants et
surtout pardon ma valeur mais un point
essentiel besoins essentiels après je te
la question que vous posez c'est vrai
qu'on a le sentiment quand on voit ce
qu'a déclaré serey die sont à droite et
à gauche on n'a pas le sentiment jolie
franchement c'est un peu ce qu'on
ressent tous enfin la majorité que
thierry a défendu ou a pris position
pour hapsatou sy pardonnez moi je vous
dis c'est vous le savez moi je vais vous
dire aussi une chose après tout si on a
d'abord beaucoup de compassion pour elle
est pure ce qui lui arrive et on
comprend parfaitement qu'elle s'est
sentie insultée
maintenant nous on a fait notre travail
en responsabilité qui est de dire à
partir du moment où il ya des propos
dans une émission en différé
saint-julien enregistrés c'est pas la
même chose qu'en direct est la première
que là vraiment on sait ce qu'on fait et
bien à propos quand des propos sont
tenus et qu'ils sont contre la loi c'est
à dire ce qui nous a semblé être le cas
c'est à dire que ces propos pouvaient
être considérées comme des incitations à
la discrimination ma part dont on a un
patron de chaîne on a le csa
qui nous fait l'honneur de ne pas
supporter l'idée que ces propos soient
diffusés et nous évidemment qu'on a
trouvé que ses propos ne devaient pas
être diffusé et on les a en
responsabilité mais reid responsable
pardon mais voilà maintenant thierry
comme moi on a appelé absatou 6 vendredi
matin j'ai appelé hapsatou sy longuement
pour lui expliquer notre point de vue on
lui avait expliqué la veille aussi au
soir que ce n'était pas difficile
pas si simple que ça et que ça se
réglerait pas juste sur une injonction
donc on a expliqué à us à tous qu'on
était obligé que le service juridique
s'était penché sur la question que la
direction de ces huit s'était penché sur
la question et qu'on ne pouvait pas
maintenir ses propos dans l'émission
thierry c'est pas parce que il n'a pas
passé son temps au téléphone a rappelé
hapsatou qu'il n'était pas solidaire de
ce que j'ai dit ah ben ça tout est par
ailleurs comment voulez vous joindre
quelqu'un qui ne décroche plus son
téléphone c'est très compliqué nous on
adore ça tourne a jamais eu de problème
ça fait un an plus d'un an qu'on bosse
avec elle
ça fait plus d'un an qu'elle ne s'est
jamais plaint une seule fois du montage
de l'émission on a un souci
on est là pour en discuter mais pour
discuter faut être deux voilà ses
problèmes d'argent
vous l'avez mal compris je crois que
vous l'avez mal compris il a voulu dire
mais le conte il avait peut-être
peut-être ça arrive parfois qu'on se
fasse mal compris
excusez moi dites moi qu'est ce qu'on
voulait dire par là c'est que on a on
est tellement proche d'absa tout entre
guillemets que on lui fait même des
facilités pour que vraiment rien à voir
je suis d'accord avec vous ça n'a rien à
voir
est ce que je voulais dire c'est qu'elle
bénéficie d'un excellent traitement sein
de l'ip jamais je ne peux pas supporter
moi l'idée qu'on pense que absatou et
maltraité par la production je vais vous
dire la vérité ça ça me chante re
considère qu'on était là nue dans cette
émission
la preuve c'est que nous les avons coupé
est ce que c'est clair il était une
chaleur énorme mais il n'est pas d'une
chaleur aidant vous trouvez à l'heure et
n'ont rien dans cette affaire née d'une
chaleur
ni ni ni ni la manière et pardonnez moi
est ce que c'est bien que quelqu'un qui
est qui et dans notre émission décide de
passer par dessus notre tête par dessus
la c8 et de ses problématiques
mais après l'entraînement d'information
de contre vérités qui ont peut-être
qu'ils ont fait à gaza my il ya deux
choses ces femmes et savez que j'aime
les missions et voilà mais oui a déjà on
le sait j'adore cette émission je la
regarde assidûment là j'ai été choqué
par deux choses d'abord que thierry
ardisson ne la soutiennent pas à ce
moment là déjà il n'ya pas qu'eux qui
est agressé ce que mc santé offerts
chaque colonie se fait mouche ministre
ou de toi tu devrais appeler nathalie
gilles william goldnadel ses limites et
l'amour des gens qui se font agresser et
l'adf j'ai repris je suis désolé de dire
quand même qu'on s'acharne sur deux
phrases qui ont été coupées sciemment et
volontairement parce qu'elle est belle
contrevenait à ce qui nous paraissait de
notre devoir de responsabilité mais
pendant deux heures absatou a pu
débattre avec avec eric zemmour et elle
a dit plein de choses intéressantes et
elle s'est très bien défendu on a eu de
longues discussions et pendant cette
émission on a fait aussi un reportage où
on est allé voir vincent cerrutti est
absente ou six pour parler du racisme
qui ne suivent d'ailleurs je voyais un
mécène chambre il faut des choses le
premier soir c'est ça la fefa des femmes
contre elle contrôle dans la loi mais
quand même qu'on voit les images et
thierry se marre quand il fait c'est
quand il fait ses injonctions pas et
d'assurance aussi non mais attendez le
truc dans leur contexte que eric zemmour
se permettent de dire natacha polony
tu devrais appeler nathalie williams
excellent savane dans sa tête il dit
quoi à force de vous entendre eric
zemmour tout le monde va s'appeler fnath
et parce que ça aussi c'est dans le
calendrier chrétien fête nationale donc
je crois vous ne faites pas de mauvais
une mauvaise interprétation d'image que
vous interprétez a posteriori et madré
juste à christine kelly parce que là
vous aimez travailler au csa vous
connaissez parfaitement ce qu'est la loi
ce qui peut aussi pas possible marouvin
question c'est est-ce que cette touriste
quelque chose en ayant publié la vidéo
d'anonymat une vidéo qui a été coupé par
le pro
docteur dans l'accord avec la chaîne
parce que les propos et n'était pas
diffusable sur ça il n'y a pas de débat
alors les bretons alors la chaîne et on
est tenu par des textes juridiques avec
le csa qui dit pas d'incitation à la
haine en vis-à-vis de la banque c'est
pour dire que premier moyen ce niveau-là
de chaînes ils ont extrêmement bien fait
et le csa pourrait même les féliciter
d'avoir coupé cette séquence est
important de le savoir
deuxièmement lorsque cette séquence est
diffusée sur les réseaux sociaux
elle ne risque que le tribunal
correctionnel c'est à dire où et même
eric zemmour ne risque que le tribunal
correctionnel et l'a déjà été condamné
pour incitation à la haine pas le csa
parce que le csa ne va intervenir que si
c'est diffusé sur une chaîne que si par
exemple vous diffusé l'extrait
maintenant puisque vous n'avez pas fait
et ça c'est bien ai je fait aussi la
différence comme l'ail comme l'a
souligné stéphane simon la différence
entre une chaîne entre une émission en
direct comme celle ci qui a souvent un
des risques parce que l'émission est en
direct une émission enregistrée une m le
csa est plus strict plus dur avec une
émission enregistrée et aurait été
beaucoup plus dur avec un look il ya eu
déjà des andonces dire que si je résume
les propos ont été diffusés sur les
réseaux un ils sont condamnables et
condamnable en justice en justice sont
exploitables
donc les propos justice sont
condamnables et appui total à la fois
les propos d'eric zemmour sont
condamnables en justice pour incitation
à la haine et à la fois la chaîne c8 et
le producteur peuvent se retourner
contre accepte aussi pour avoir diffusé
sans l'autorisation
les images de la chaîne vous avez voulu
médiatiser quand vous avez des images
vous avez pensé quoi vous de cette
séquence n'est pas que c'est quand j'ai
vu les images je vous dis très
sincèrement que j'aurais été membre du
csa que j'aurais condamné la chaîne
immédiatement sanctionnée pour
incitation à la haine avec l'avait
laissé avec n'y avait pas avec ce qui a
été absent qui n'a pas été dit et bah
y'a pas de débat après la question qu'on
peut se poser est là qui a été un peu
soulevé c'est à dire est ce que et là il
faut regarder toutes les missions
lorsqu'on invite eric zemmour on sait
qu'on prend des risques
est-ce que là il ya eu un répondant
est-ce que là l'animateur comme sur tous
les plateaux il est passé aujourd'hui
est ce que l'animateur est le pendant
est ce que l'animateur va contre est
dans l'opposition on ne peut pas laisser
eric zemmour tout dire on sait que c'est
un polémiste et le csa veut regarder
tout ce qui est diffusé sur tout sur
toutes les chaînes en ce moment pouvoir
est ce que l'animateur le journaliste
qui leur soit retravaillé c'était son
travail christiane dessau de noms de
ceux du plateau c'est vrai que s'ils
savent et et cyril lui il aurait défendu
bec et ongles hapsatou contre contre
vents et marées moi je suis si ça avait
été la santé je trouve que c'est mon
époux n'est pas l'émission comme je suis
incurablement raisonnable pour ce genre
de choses et que j'aime bien avoir tous
les éléments pour juger je suis
entièrement d'accord avec ces sentiments
je souscris à tout ce qu'il dit et j'ai
toutes les réponses en l'écoutant
honnêtement moi j'ai été choqué cap 7 ou
diffusent des images qui n'était pas
qu'ils avaient été coupés je sais
j'aurais été choqué que la chaîne
évidemment ne coupe pas ces images et je
ne comprends pas qu'on fasse un tel
débat autour du mal nous propos qui
justement à sept-îles tenu
officiellement je vais vous donner on
diffuse pas la séquence envie de vous
donner une phrase d'accord c'est zemmour
qui part dans la phrase qui a été coupée
mademoiselle c'est votre prénom qui est
une insulte à la france donc ça marche
est extrêmement choquée je trouve
monsieur je vous le dirai tout est
heureusement que votre attitude allait
indigne et c'est le tiret redescend
aussi dire vous jeter en pâture votre
chroniqueuse vous ne soutenez pas vos
équipes en séries le nunavik et des
renaissants de vous la laissez vous la
laissez vous dit tu n'as pas les
meurtres et absatou si elle est meurtrie
des mêmes femmes brisées aujourd'hui
sens et vous la laissez en pleine nature
hanche magazine jour était de son côté
la route n'est ce pas vous faites bien
blanc ne tient elle répond pas excusé
non plus tout devrait enfin franchement
excusez moi mais en l'occurrence absatou
et on est de son côté la meilleure
preuve c'est qu'on conséquences qui nous
avons et elle voulait qu'on l'a dit le
russe vous saviez qu'elle allait la
diffuser
c'était ma finale et c'est en pleine
nature mais là je vais envoyer tiens tu
veux nous avons cédé à la nuit 3000 sage
aujourd'hui en lui demandant tu viens
bien je dis mais pour que vous n'avez
pas qu'un jour sans que cet album serait
pas rouvert c'est ce que hapsatou peux
comprendre qu'à la fois on peut être
d'accord avec elle et ne pas lui laisser
faire n'importe quoi les konan aisément
alors fin d'année les honda mais
qu'est-ce que mega man d'années je peux
dire gagner et je ne sais pas et même à
traiter ou paie cette séquence bien que
je souhaitais les scandales et ses pavés
pour hadji c'est pas la peine de faire
le numéro fait jusqu'ici je n'ai rien à
me reprocher et j'ai fait mon travail de
producteur et moi tu fais juste là deux
des tubes de cascades pour faire du buzz
produire très bien que nous avons fait
notre travail d'acteur qu'il alors des
sérieuses ses fans ça va au delà de la
séquence en parallèle oui avec zemmour
sur lci a tenté de se dédouaner et de
minimiser les propos qu'il a tenus sur
le plateau des terriens du samedi et
simplement ce qui a provoqué la colère
d'apps à tous venez la diffusion
pourrait s'agit siégeant suis comptable
mois de ça est ce que je suis je ne suis
pas comptable des propos d'éric saillour
commun sauf s'ils les tient dans mon
émission qui les tient dans d'autres
émissions
je ne peux rien faire en revanche moi ce
que je peux te dire c'est capsat où je
n'ai cessé de lui dire tu es la
bienvenue dans l'émission et qui à un
moment si elle ne veut plus venir dans
l'émission c'est un cas de conscience
pour elle et vous
si je vous dis aussi elle est la
bienvenue
non je sais pas si je pense qu'il faut
que les esprits s'apaisent sociaux
allaient cependant de se rebeller de
discuter et de préparer l'émission big
shaqtus lancé à l'émission elle est
après demain et on n'a pas commencé à
bosser ah oui on oublie que les choses
essentielles dans ce débat quand même
c'est un drap physique et l'état mental
d'absa pussy j'eus 11 j'ai vu son clan
qui qui m'a raconté qu'elle était
dévastée en fait et là je pense que lui
même pourtant débat comme ça on oublie
c'est une femme meurtrie
c'est une tannerie qu'il n'y a pas de
mots pour dire que l'on puisse
comprendre ce qu'elle vit on puisse être
et bien les séquences quelles sont-elles
plus longtemps j'adore mais nous avons
fait nos mesures dérogatoires
c'est pas possible on peut parler de son
argent comme ça j'aime être en fait un
coup de couteau au trauma de lui sur le
feu c'est c'est très humiliant
ça relève de la jument river et les
impôts le montant des impôts de chacun
on s'en fout on n'a pas besoin de savoir
ça en fait
et ça gèle mais dire qui va du côté
d'axa tout si c'est très humiliant libye
puisse commencer à taper sur le système
de thierry comme ça me tape sur le
système de venir me défendre alors que
je fais mon travail et vous avez
quelqu'un du csa va ex c'est sa part de
christine qui vous explique que nous
avons fait un travail et je me fais
engueuler mais enfin vous n'êtes pas
sérieux après il faut alors vous allez y
on vous en parlait tout la joie
cyniquement ya pas de chine espère bien
que d'une écoute on dit pas que le
travail est fait juridiquement pas
attendez quand même que dont ce qu'on a
pu lire de ci de là aux déclarations de
l'un des autres on n'est pas senti une
chaleur de la part de la production et
des et des propos réconfortants pour
après tout si on n'est pas autre chose
on veut pas un procès on a juste que
quelqu'un qui visiblement est assez
froid est assez basique sur des faits
qui sont à mon sens totalement ignoble
et je pense que effectivement ce qui est
ressenti ses pénates à contre vous c'est
que la communication quand ces deux
indices ont été la vôtre et d'air on
parle de chaume à fait si on a fait ça
mais il ya une femme blessée qui pour le
coup ne se sent pas m
tenue les 6 meilleurs niveaux trop de
blessés durant la soirée vous croyez que
ça a été une partie de plaisir mais
nadal s'est fait engueuler comme du
poisson pourri par eric zemmour avec des
arguments assez basses et vindicatif
ainsi est-ce que vous croyez que ça a
été une partie de plaisir mais c'est
quelqu'un de très dur
eric zemmour très très dur très violent
mais pour nous mais je ne voudrais pas
qu'on pense qu'il n'y a eu que absatou
qui a été meurtri mais elle est là un
peu plus de raison que les haussiers à
la couleur de la peau grasse à tous je
suis désolé vous n'êtes pas à dire ça
prend pas pour un habit et dans ce cas
là je dis je suis tout arrive et
solidaire de la peine qu'elle a ressenti
mais mais ça ne justifie pas de faire
n'importe quoi derrière mon il y en a
sur cette question est ce que vous ne
vous êtes choqués par voilà est-ce qu'il
aurait dû défendre est aussi ont dit oui
à 79% parce que 4 1% et c'était juste
propos que les choses étaient faites
entend régler en temps et en heure
évidemment il n'y a pas de débat sur ça
on n'y met d'accord stevan maintenant
que le ressenti d'une femme blessée
abandonnés et choqués les gens je peux
l'entendre et on peut l'entendre c'était
pas plus grave que ça je vous dis
franchement